enlargement has been I think a massive  achievement I mean let me say this  personally when I arrived in Brussels in  1985 we were 10 member states we are now  28 that's a revolution and actually if  you asked countries outside of the  European Union a lot of them want to get  it I mean you get the debate in the  Ukraine for instance because they see  that it offers you a platform and it  offers you a community which allows you  to develop yourself it allows you to  develop low a legal system a system of  an internal market which functions and  all of that again I do not want to say  that the Union is a panacea it solves  all your problems automatically you have  to work very hard yourself within this  framework but it does and enlargement I  think if you think that now we have  countries which 20 years ago belonged to  the Soviet Union and they are now  members one of them Lithuania has just  had the presidency for six months I  think it's absolutely it's a miracle